wer weiß schon freuen
jeder tag ist
er weiß schon heute morgen sind immer
wieder als neue geht so guten morgen
heute weihnachten und bevor es richtig
losgeht mache ich das letzte türchen
auch von meinem adventskalender
und mal fragen was drin schokolade sehr
gut den tüv ist auch der turbinen hier
der core i mein zwillingsbruder unsere
mama wann werden wir dann heute abend
essen ab 57
ja also half ihr nein das ist zu spät
plötzlich hat sich um halb fünf bei der
oma und danach
danach sind wir dann bei uns dann haben
wir endlich holen
aber bevor wirklich der weihnachtsstress
es richtig losgeht werden wir wichtig
das machen wir mit unseren geschwistern
level anfangen richtig funktioniert so
man sieht einen namen von freunden die
da mitmachen und dem kaufmann dann ein
geschenk das kann auch so kommt sie denn
dass man einfach ein geschenk kauft und
dann werden quasi die geschenke gezogen
danke ich dir das zu verdanken
dann kann es sein dass du irgendwie in
damenpaar bekommst du wohl du ein typ
ist und das auch noch
und habt ihr schon gesungen
so belaufen
sommerzeit
den rest machen
wir sind jetzt hier bei meinen eltern im
haus das sie mir aufgewachsen
genau jetzt müssen wir erstmal alles
vorbereiten fürs essen wir machen ja
klett
diese familie schon immer ein
familienfest gewesen
er fuhr zusammen sein weihnachten ist
ein schöner anlass dafür also an
weihnachten kommen zu uns nicht der
weihnachtsmann und das christkind das
christkind läutet dann ist quasi
bescherung voraus fest euch und wir
sehen uns später das ist ein semester
noch mal zur nächsten folgen